beauté internet
[musique]
Mahina I quand je nous donne la lumière et Internet
à un moment je montrerai
et nous avons des cornes lumineuses
Donc
Nous y sommes parfois contraints par les managers
prêt
a donné des insultes et des coutures brillantes Danka a oublié
sauce et a donné à tilki pedgria de l'eau de
couper les macaronis et nous sommes tous dans la soirée
prêt avec les enfants
Le cola est léger à laver, nous nous préparons à
dors nous nageons
[musique]
semelles donc
marcher nourrir Chuck Quoi d'autre est nécessaire ici
faire
quelque chose qui remplit
donne de la force
la nature est probablement la seule chose
peut-être dans ce cas
remplissez-le bien Foi Oui et la nature
ulcératif
ton côté n'était rien après tout
des vies politiques peut-être là-bas
célébrités
le côté positif de nous les gens est devenu
moins d'ukraine plus d'amour chez vous
Et
se peignent élémentaires pour s'entendre
appel téléphonique du matin de maman de papa
leur souhaiter bonne nuit
tout est calme la nuit s'est passée tranquillement
donne tellement
la charge et la tranquillité d'esprit que vous
comprendre que fondamentalement
assez
une personne vraiment heureuse
[musique]
notre gouvernement régional local a échoué
l'administration de crise s'est tue en même temps
5 jours Quand on comprenait déjà que Kherson
a pris 6 heures et certainement les gens
peur que nous soyons dans
l'occupation et ces cocktails de protection
Molotov Et les sacs de sable sont devenus les leurs
type
papier de tournesol à
comprendre qu'Odessa ne peut tout simplement pas
prendre
Vous savez
[musique]
volontairement
culturel
Commentaires
Quels sont les liens de la Yakoutie pour nous ou
conseiller d'autoroute Alors tu aimes les plats de yaki
être des choses
avec les Russes, les reliques avaient jusqu'à 24 ans
1 sac humain si 24 ans tu es dans notre
de notre côté de nos niches de look
des gens de valeur ces gens que nous connaissions
Si les vagues arpentaient les masques
calomnié parce que les bains aujourd'hui
appelle les gens
personnes mal placées
nos villes sont nos habitants
alors le mouvement de la régularité de la régularité
de nos spivados serpentins
[musique]
En ce moment, c'est moderne en millions
Inspection des objets exposés
First de Group C'est votre nom Personnes
crochet
De Nikolaïev Kharkiv